yo I had to wait till my dad fell asleep
so I could steal his keys
ready
I was born ready
Swanson
easy sure careful
all right
this is a mistake why would you call it
that on your menu I don't know what to
tell you man
just give me all the bacon and eggs you
have
wait wait I worry what you just heard
was give me a lot of bacon and eggs what
I said was
give me all the bacon and eggs you have
do you understand
this came out yeah
I am starving I haven't had lunch since
yesterday so I'm gonna head over to
Callahan's oh no no don't go there they
totally skimp on pickles let me go to
big head Joe's for you they have the
most insane burritos I don't much go for
ethnic food trust me they have one
that's called the meat tornado
literally killed the guy last year
you had me at me tornado
I'm sorry about Andy but I'm not sorry
about what I did
what's my crime
I got bold
and a little negligent nope
my office now
hey
you smoking here you don't smoke just
asking if I can
are you high
I'm high on kaboom
don't ask for permission ask for
forgiveness that's right you never did
ask me for permission did you well I'm
sorry to burst your kabubble but I just
had my ass handed to me by the city
manager and now this entire department
is castrued
Ron I'm so so sorry
what the
were you thinking I would prefer that
she asked me for my permission so I can
say no I like saying no
it lowers their enthusiasm
I'm hungry
okay well don't be such a baby I cooked
you some bacon for a trail snack I ate
it already
I could smell it in your purse before I
even park my car and now it's gone and I
hate everything
Ron Swanson will be next
when it comes to government hearings the
only type of witness I enjoy being is a
hostile one
that's why I intend to answer every one
of their questions with a question
were you aware that all of the
entertainment and food was provided by
Rec Center teachers would I have stayed
if I knew that I don't know what do you
have what do you have no I wouldn't have
did you hear Leslie make any promises
what constitutes a promise
a quid pro quo oh do you know Latin okay
thank you Ron
are we done would you like to sample our
vegan bacon 100 meatless yes please
another please
sir is there a problem I'm just making
sure no one ever has to eat this
I I don't think I can give you any more
I want one
okay
Pierre Garcon was a six round pick Kali
was the fourth round Indianapolis Colts
know how to draft so well they really do
Andy this was delicious it's awesome
it's a whole new meat delivery system
thank you son what do you say we go out
to the parking lot run a few pass plays
to burn off the calories you are an
Unstoppable good idea machine
I like Andy I'm surrounded by a lot of
women in this department
and that includes the men
Peyton Manning reading the defense
Reggie Wayne both corner
[Laughter]
anything up Ron let's cut the bowl I
want me Tom and all the other ladies
included on your hunting trip
hunting trip
we're doing a trail survey Leslie we're
literally listening to turkey calls is
this is this not rap
foreign
can you make the opening remarks I I
just I'm not in the mood neither am I
ever what's wrong with you you live for
this kind of stuff I don't have it in me
right now Ron please do it for me make
the speech Ron please please give the
speech from no yes please Ron please
please give a speech please give the
speech yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes please please please please please
please please please please please
please please please yes yes all right
damn it woman
okay everyone shut up
and look at me
welcome divisions of nature
this room has several paintings in it
some are big some are small people did
them and they are here now I believe
that after this is over they'll be hung
in government buildings why the
government is involved in an art show is
beyond me
I also think it's pointless for a human
to paint scenes of nature when they
could just go outside and stand in it
anyway please do not misinterpret the
fact that I am talking right now as
genuine interest in art and attempt to
discuss it with me further end of speech
run
run wake up Ron wake up it's Leslie
are you having a bad dream no I suffer
from a disorder called Sleep fighting
terrible only one I'm losing
it's really good to see you Ron
you've aged horribly
oh my God
what's your problem nothing's changed
has it we set the bed on fire excuse me
I did okay is that what you want to eat
we're fine we're fine
when you meddle in someone's personal
life it's just so rewarding
oh yes
yes I've got it
visual place
[Laughter]
hey if you see Andy will you not tell
him I'm here okay because of what
happened I don't want him to think stop
don't want to know the less I know about
other people's Affairs the happier I am
I'm not interested in caring about
people
I once worked with a guy for three years
and never learned his name
best friend I ever had
we still never talk sometimes
we're down Leslie
I thought I was supposed to lay the
ceremonial wreath wise councilman Hauser
doing it because you are doing
something better you are lighting the
memorial flame which is the greatest
honor of all oh my God Ron
congratulations I shaved it for you Ron
who caught you guys
a very nosy maintenance worker and we
talked to him and now we're all friends
and he's not going to tell him
absolutely fine I think if you would
know one thing about me it would be that
I prefer laying wreaths to lighting
torches
I have cried twice in my life
once when I was seven and I was hit by a
school bus
and then again when I heard that little
Sebastian had passed
his memory
will live on as today we light a fire
that will burn on for eternity oh my God
okay deep breath I think we got through
it yeah hey Jerry you put propane in the
Eternal Flame right no they were out and
so I just got a big thing of lighter
fluid it's kind of the same thing
excuse me
there's a sign at rampsit Park that says
do not drink the sprinkler water so I
made some tea with it and now I have an
infection
sir
sir are are you listening to me sir sir
I'm talking to you
sir
sir are you aware that there is waste in
your water system
Tom and April were excellent Witnesses
in my defense unfortunately every single
word out of their mouths was a lie
there's only one thing I hate more than
lying skim milk which is water that's
lying about being milk
all right